sweat it's a beautiful day you're gonna
burn my truck I'm going
the time
on the wall
the love
hello wastelanders and welcome back
after the long Christmas break we hope
you've had a lovely holiday and all that
but unfortunately the new year is about
getting rid of all the bad habits you've
gained over the past few months or years
or your entire life so put the turkey
legs down pick up a self-help book and
grow yourself some willpower it's time
to get stuck into your new year's
resolutions countless studies have shown
that improving yourself is hard and dull
and difficult to keep up but we like to
think that video games are a great
teaching tool here at gamespot so we
thought it might be nice to have a
little look and how fallouts inhabitants
are handling their resolutions it's
going to be inspiring probably if you
find these hot tips in any way helpful
first of all thanks for humoring us but
also be sure to share your own gaming
resolutions in the comments or you can
get on twitter using the hashtag g as
fallout let's get resolution in probably
the most common new year's resolution
it's also the one most likely to be
dumped on the doorstep of the gym after
your first sweaty session on a treadmill
get some motivation and maybe it won't
be so easy to give up there are loads of
ways to lose weight more exercise less
food gain haircut stop being pregnant
never wear clothes again chop off one of
your limbs if all you're concerned about
is the number on that scale why not
ditch everything that's weighing you
down whether you're on a health care
cord just kicking out bad habits smoking
is a good one to choose think what you
could do with all that extra moon space
nothing wrong with a bit of social
lubrication but when it gets the point
that you're licking lamp posts and
declaring to everyone that you love them
even if you've never seen them before
and they're also a lamppost then maybe
just maybe you have a problem so you've
given up your bad habits your buff and
you're always on time but wouldn't it be
nice to show all that off to someone
special what's the point in having an
awesome six-pack if no one ever sees it
now you've got all this free money that
you're not spending on booze and burgers
you can afford to go on holiday sure it
might just be staying a crappy cabin an
hour's drive away from home even baby
steps you're important when it'd be nice
to be able to find your keys phone
wallet or trousers fallout 4 is in great
for organization unless you enjoy
putting all your stuff in vaguely
labeled piles but would it be nice to
sort of the contents of your pockets by
weight and value maybe you've got
everything else sorted in your life
you've been buff an excellent since
birth Avenue use superstar why not share
your excellent life with a small fluffy
thing or a large scale ething or maybe
you hate small fluffy things and large
scaly things and what you're really
looking for is a pudgy sad stinky thing
not the babies aren't great they're just
a bit of a pain to take care of
especially when they get kidnapped if
you haven't had enough family after the
Christmas break why not have a bit more
there's nothing more precious than
spending time with your family before
it's too late and sometimes when it is
already too late oh well sports we all
like to kick the ball into the thing
right and we like scoring points for
doing it why not do that a bit more it
counts as exercise after all and
probably spending more quality time with
family if you manage to wrote your
siblings in those so there are our new
year's resolutions fallout 4 style some
successful some less successful and some
kind of stupid we'd love to hear yours
both of their games related or not so
drop them in the comments and we'll
cheer you on from over here you can do
it so that's all we've got time for this
week but make sure you share your
awesome creations with us using the
hashtag GS fallout or you can leave them
in the comments section below remember
to subscribe to the fallout show on
YouTube and make sure you come back next
week for a new episode and stay safe out
there wastelander
it